Trascrizione: Carlotta Vielmo
Revisore: Inesse Saidani
Quanti di voi scrivono
con la mano sinistra?
Potreste alzare la mano per favore?
Potete usare indifferentemente
la destra o la sinistra.
Bravi, così a occhio e croce, secondo me,
sarete circa un centinaio.
Mi dicono che in teatro
ci sono circa 800 persone,
per cui siete attorno al 10-15%.
Questa, in realtà, è la percentuale
che si osserva in qualsiasi
sottoinsieme dell'umanità,
ovunque, a qualsiasi
latitudine.
Dove ci sono esseri umani,
c'è una maggioranza che predilige
usare la mano destra
e una minoranza che preferisce
usare la mano sinistra.
E se ci pensate è una cosa strana, no?
Perché non è metà e metà?
Perché non 50 e 50?
O perché non l'unanimità,
per esempio?
Perché non 100%
che preferiscono la mano destra
e 100% che preferiscono la mano sinistra?
Io oggi provo a illustrarvi un'idea
che cerca di spiegare
perché c'è questa condizione
di maggioranza e minoranza.
Allora, tutti sanno che
la faccenda della preferenza nell'uso
della mano ha che fare con il cervello,
con il fatto che la parte destra
controlla l'arto di sinistra
e viceversa.
E, inoltre, con il fatto che le due metà
del sistema nervoso
fanno cose diverse,
per esempio, nella nostra specie
l'emisfero sinistro si occupa
del linguaggio
mentre l'emisfero destro
è affaccendato con altre cose,
tipo riconoscere le facce,
orientarsi nello spazio e così via.
Quello che forse non sapete
è che questi fenomeni sono generali,
sono diffusi anche in altri animali.
Per esempio, se prendete gli scimpanzé
gli date un tubetto con dentro del miele,
loro, di solito, lo tengono
con la sinistra, come faremmo noi
e con la destra manipolano
per tirare fuori il miele.
Oppure, un po' più lontani da noi,
questi rospi, li abbiamo studiati anni fa,
gli abbiamo messo un pezzettino
di nastro adesivo sul muso
e abbiamo visto che per toglierselo
con la zampina
usano preferenzialmente
la zampa destra.
O ancora, alcune asimmetrie
sono addirittura più forti
di quelle che osserviamo
per l'uso della mano destra
nella nostra specie.
I pappagalli, di solito
usano la zampa posteriore sinistra
per tenere gli oggetti
e poi manipolano, per così dire,
utilizzando il becco
e lo fanno in percentuali
che sono attorno al 90%,
quindi, ancor più alte
di quelle della nostra preferenza
per l'uso della mano destra.
Ci sono animali che non hanno degli arti
in senso proprio
o che non li usano.
Ma, comunque,
siccomeil fenomeno è relativo
alla specializzazione diversa
della parte destra e sinistra,
noi possiamo osservare,
comunque, delle differenze.
Per esempio,
gli animali che hanno gli occhi
posizionati lateralmente sul capo,
molti uccelli, pesci, rettili,
hanno un'organizzazione anatomica
tale per cui
--quella che vedete qua--
quello che viene visto
dall'occhio destro,
viene elaborato dall'emisfero
sinistro e viceversa.
Allora, se prendete, per esempio,
un polletto come questo, o un piccione
e lo lasciate libero di beccare
una teoria di grannellini,
potete scoprire, dopo un po'
--adesso il filmato verrà accelerato,
perché non abbiamo tanto tempo--
che la distribuzione delle beccate
non è simmetrica.
in realtà, il pulcino becca
molto di più sul lato sinistro
che non sul lato destro.
Perché?
Perché l'emisfero destro è
--come dire--
controlla questi comportamenti
viso-spaziali
e dirige l'attenzione
nella parte sinistra del mondo.
È interessante questo fenomeno,
perché, in realtà,
lo potete osservare
anche nella nostra specie,
in una forma diversa.
Per esempio, in giochetti come questi:
qual è che mi sembra la faccina triste
e quale la faccina allegra?
La maggior parte delle persone,
i destrimani, perlomeno,
dicono che la faccina di sinistra
sembra allegra
e quella di destra sembra triste.
Questo succede perché
noi dirigiamo l'attenzione
sulla parte sinistra del viso.
Allora, potete vedere
che sulla parte sinistra del viso
la bocca va all'insù, mentre invece
sulla parte destra va all'ingiù.
E questo, per così dire, colora
l'impressione dell'intera faccetta.
È una fortuna che dirigiamo l'attenzione
sulla parte sinistra,
perché anche le emozioni
sul nostro volto vengono espresse
più intensamente
sulla parte sinistra del volto.
Non so se avete mai notato,
ma gran parte dei ritratti,
in ogni epoca e con diversi stili,
i modelli e tendono a mostrare
il lato sinistro del viso.
Questo è il famoso Antonello da Messina,
e il sorriso dell'ignoto marinaio,
ma vale anche per Monna Lisa.
Le asimmetrie che sto descrivendo
non riguardano solo la vista,
valgono per tutti gli organi di senso.
Per esempio, noi abbiamo studiato nei cani
l'uso della narice destra e sinistra.
Vedete che loro alternano
l'uso delle due narici,
fanno una specie di scanning
e non lo fanno a caso, in realtà.
Cioè, con stimoli nuovi
tendono a usare più la narice di destra,
che è connessa direttamente
--l'olfatto è un senso antico--
con l'emisfero destro.
E poi ancora, in certi casi le differenze
di lato si possono manifestare
anche per organi che non sono doppi
come gli occhi, le orecchie e così via,
ma che sono singoli, mediali,
per esempio la coda.
Allora, i cani, quando scodinzolano
muovono la coda sia a destra
che a sinistra, ovviamente.
Però, siccome il movimento
a destra o a sinistra
è controllato dal lato opposto
del sistema nervoso,
succede che
se voi misurate l'entità
dello scodinzolamento
quando, per esempio, un cagnolino
guarda il padrone,
e quindi è contento,
e vedete che muove la coda
un po' di più a destra
e tocca il fianco destro
molto di più di quanto non tocchi
quello sinistro.
Adesso lo stesso cane
guarda un altro cane
in atteggiamento, invece, aggressivo.
Vedete che lo scodinzolio
--e questo non sorprende-- diminuisce,
ma tende anche a spostarsi
sul lato sinistro.
Questo succede perché,
mentre le emozioni positive sono
controllate dall'emisfero sinistro,
che induce una risposta
di approccio, di avvicinamento,
quelle negative
che vi fan tornare indietro, per così dire
sono controllate dall'emisfero destro.
Voi direte:
"Beh, bel lavoro che fate voi scienziati,
studiare i movimenti della coda del cane".
Devo dire che qui ho perso un'occasione
per diventare ricco,
perché una ditta americana,
senza dirci niente,
ha sfruttato le nostre osservazioni
e ha inventato un piccolo marchingegno
che, posto sulla coda dei cani,
consente di misurare
se scodinzolano
un po' di più a destra o a sinistra.
E, quindi, i proprietari possono stabilire
se il loro cane è felice oppure no.
Non garantisco che funzioni.
Allora,
succedono un sacco di cose
interessanti e strane, no?
Per quello che riguarda
la destra e la sinistra,
nel mondo naturale degli animali.
Quindi, quando un ranocchio vede
qualche cosa di buono,
è più facile che lui lo pigli
con un colpo di lingua
se lo vede con l'occhio destro
che non con l'occhio sinistro.
La differenza è relativa,
non è assoluta, ma c'è.
Oppure, se, invece di mangiare, si tratta
di aggredire un altro conspecifico.
Per esempio,
queste sono lucertole americane.
Quando due maschi si incontrano
è più facile che si attacchino
se si vedono con l'occhio sinistro
che non con l'occhio destro.
E anche la livrea cambia di colore.
Associato al comportamento
aggressivo
--più facilmente se si vedono
con l'occhio sinistro--
è un fatto generale,
vale per tutti i vertebrati.
Quindi, adesso, quando andate in giro
sul marciapiede
con un accompagnatore, un'accompagnatrice,
considerate con attenzione
se la volete tenere
alla vostra destra o alla vostra sinistra,
a seconda di quello che vi aspettate
da lui o da lei.
Però, noterete, c'è un problema qui.
il problema è che
questo è un modo apparentemente molto
strano di costruire un cervello, giusto?
Perché, nel mondo, gli oggetti, le prede,
i predatori, gli altri animali,
hanno, in linea di principio,
la stessa probabilità di apparire
a destra o a sinistra.
Per cui, in questioni
che sono veramente di vita o di morte,
come, per esempio,
rispondere a un predatore,
una situazione in cui il nostro ranocchio
è più veloce,
un po' più veloce a rispondere
se il predatore arriva da sinistra
e non da destra,
sembra un modo strano per l'evoluzione,
per la selezione naturale,
di costruire un cervello.
Quindi, ci devono essere state ragioni.
Importanti ragioni per costruire
i cervelli asimmetrici.
Quali?
Beh, alcune le conosciamo,
ce n'è più d'una.
Per esempio, se allochiamo,
mettiamo le funzioni da una parte,
risparmiamo tessuto nervoso.
Quindi, metto il linguaggio
nell'emisfero sinistro,
ho un po' di spazio nel destro
per metterci delle altre cose.
Come sempre, in biologia,
il vantaggio è una questione relativa,
perché succede che se vi capita
di avere una lesione,
l'altro emisfero non è in grado
di sostenere quella funzione.
Ed è quello che capita se, per disgrazia,
avete una lesione all'emisfero sinistro,
diventate afasici.
Oppure, considerate il caso degli animali
di cui vi parlavo prima,
che hanno gli occhi posizionati
lateralmente sul capo,
a destra e a sinistra.
Allora, per loro si pone il problema
di come controllare l'azione.
Considerate ancora il nostro ranocchio.
Di qua vede una mosca
e di qua un'altra mosca
e si trova, come il famoso asino
di Buridano, incapace di decidere.
In queste situazioni è assolutamente
essenziale che una metà del cervello
assuma il controllo e dica: "Ok, si va
a destra, si mangia la mosca di destra".
E poi, infine, c'è una terza
ragione importante,
che è quella che ha a che fare
con la possibilità di compiere
due compiti simultaneamente.
Visto che parliamo di volo,
le galline, che come sapete
sono il mio animale favorito,
e il vertice della creazione
dal punto di vista cerebrale,
sono capaci di fare una cosa
di questo tipo,
cioè di guardare sul terreno, mentre
pascolano, con l'occhio destro,
in cerca di qualche verme succulento,
e nello stesso tempo, con l'occhio
sinistro, di guardare in alto
--emisfero destro--
e tenere d'occhio l'ambiente,
che non compaia qualche predatore alato.
E questa cosa la possono fare
simultaneamente,
in maniera molto efficiente,
proprio perché hanno
un cervello asimmetrico.
Bene, questo ci dice perché, ci spiega
perché ci sono cervelli asimmetrici,
che fanno a destra e sinistra
cose diverse,
ma non ci dà ancora la risposta
al problema
con cui siamo partiti all'inizio,
e cioè: perché una maggioranza
e una minoranza?
Se ci pensate bene,
la cosa è molto strana,
perché sembrerebbe più logico
avere una condizione
in cui le asimmetrie sono distribuite
metà e metà.
Considerate questo caso:
c'è un predatore nel mondo
e il nostro predatore
ha a che fare con delle prede
che sono asimmetriche, metà e metà.
Metà sono destrimani e metà sono mancine,
diciamo così.
Allora che cosa succede?
Succede che il nostro predatore
incontra una preda
e questa scappa a destra,
ne incontra un'altra
e questa scappa a sinistra,
e un'altra ancora, e questa scapperà
non lo so, per esempio, ancora a destra,
e così via.
Ciascuna preda ha, in realtà ,
la sua direzione preferita,
però non c'è modo,
per il predatore, di saperlo,
a meno che non ci siano incontri ripetuti,
ma questo è molto improbabile, nel mare,
come potete immaginare.
Quindi, questa è una situazione
che va piuttosto bene.
Considerate, invece,
l'altra alternativa,
quella in cui le asimmetrie
sono allineate, c'è una maggioranza.
Quindi, per esempio,
arriva il nostro pesciolino
e questo pesciolino scappa a sinistra,
poi un altro, scappa a sinistra,
ancora uno, che scappa a sinistra
e un altro ancora che scappa a sinistra.
Eh beh, il predatore impara,
sfrutta tutta questa regolarità
e la può usare a proprio vantaggio.
Quindi allora uno dice:
"Ma, caspiterina, come mai si sono evolute
asimmetrie che sono simili in direzione
nella maggior parte degli individui?
Non era meglio, allora, fare metà e metà?"
Beh, la nostra idea,
molto semplicemente, è questa:
vale questo ragionamento
nell'ipotesi che
i nostri organismi siano, come dire,
totalmente solitari,
cioè, posso essere libero di decidere
se essere destrimane o mancino
senza curarmi degli altri
se non ho alcuna interazione con gli altri,
ma nel momento in cui c'è
un qualche tipo di interazione
con altri individui asimmetrici,
devo tener conto
della loro direzione di asimmetria.
Questo, nei termini della teoria
dei giochi, una branca della matematica,
si dice in questa maniera qua:
"Quel che è meglio fare
per un individuo dipende
da quello che fa la maggior parte
degli individui del gruppo cui appartiene".
Allora, apparentemente, dovreste
aspettarvi, da questo ragionamento,
che la soluzione dovrebbe, per l'appunto,
essere quella dell'allineamento.
I pesciolini stanno nei banchi,
nel mondo,
e, se tu ti allontani da solo dal banco,
sei un pesciolino morto.
In realtà no, noi abbiamo provato
a fare un po' di conti,
io con la mia collega Lesley Rogers
e Stefano Ghirlanda,
abbiamo fatto un po' di matematica
e quel che abbiamo visto,
sorprendentemente,
è che le soluzioni stabili,
cioè quelle che possono reggere
dal punto di vista dell'evoluzione,
non sono né 50%
--e l'avevamo già capito--
ma neanche 100%.
Le soluzioni che reggono sono quelle
in cui c'è una maggioranza e una minoranza:
90-10, 80-20, 60-40.
Come mai?
Beh, lo potete capire
anche senza matematica,
con un semplice esempio.
Considerate gli sport di tipo interattivo
come, per esempio, la scherma
o il pugilato, no?
Allora, nella scherma o nel pugilato,
che cos'è che succede?
Succede che voi incontrate
molti pugili che sono destrimani
e la prima volta che vi capita
di incontrare un pugile mancino
vi trovate in difficoltà.
Perché?
Perché i colpi arrivano dalla parte
che non vi aspettate.
Ricordate cosa dice Rocky Balboa
nel primo film, parlando di se stesso, no?
Era un pugile mancino:
"Nessuno vuole combattere con me".
Ma perché nessuno vuole combattere
con i mancini?
Perché i mancini sono pochi.
Perché se i mancini fossero in numero
uguale ai destrimani,
allora non avrebbero alcun vantaggio.
Questo in biologia si chiama
'selezione dipendente dalla frequenza'.
Vuol dire che il vantaggio ce l'hai
finché questi individui rimangono pochi
all'interno della popolazione.
Questa è la ragione
per cui c'è il mancinismo,
e per cui si mantiene nelle popolazioni.
Le nostre nonne erano molto preoccupate,
quando nasceva un bambino mancino,
e cercavano di correggerlo,
e dicevano: "Non devi usare
la mano del diavolo".
In realtà, come avrete capito,
il mancinismo è una condizione biologica,
del tutto naturale,
non ha niente a che fare
con il diavolo,
se non per il fatto che il diavolo
sta nei dettagli,
e il dettaglio in questo caso è relativo
al fatto che i mancini hanno il vantaggio,
possono essere originali,
per così dire,
perché stanno
in un gruppo di conformisti,
che è più grande,
che è maggioritario.
Se tra qualche migliaio d'anni
uno scienziato verrà qui
a un TED del futuro
e chiederà al suo pubblico:
"Quanti tra di voi --come ho fatto io--
usano la mano sinistra per scrivere?"
io sono pronto a scommettere
che ne salterà fuori
una percentuale identica a quella
che abbiamo trovato oggi,
cioè con una maggioranza di destrimani
e una minoranza di mancini,
che sono mantenuti a quel livello
finché son pochi.
Grazie!